notre envoyé spécial julien chez ida
bonjour julien un julien vous avez suivi
toute la journée justement a ni pro un
mouvement d' aide à l'armée et aux
volontaires un kiss qui souhaite se
battre
oui bonsoir antoine et effectivement on
a suivi ces volontaires tout au long de
la journée et là je peux vous dire que
si la guerre n'est pas présente comme à
kiev la situation est complètement
différente ici ici tout est calme et la
guerre est très présente dans les
esprits des habitants ça il n'y a pas en
douter nous avons suivi ces volontaires
qui en fait sont des gens qui viennent
spontanément donné de la nourriture des
produits de première nécessité des
vêtements qui font des cartons
gigantesque qui sont destinés à être
envoyés aux soldats et aux personnes qui
combattent pour l'armée ukrainienne
contre les russes un peu partout dans le
pays c'est un véritable élan de
solidarité nationale là vous ne pouvez
pas le voir parce qu'on à l'extérieur
mais à l'intérieur je peux vous dire que
c'était une véritable fourmilière tout à
l'heure ça ça bougeait de partout
c'était vraiment il y avait une vraie
frénésie d'unités c'était vraiment très
intéressant à voir et les gens nous ont
été très clair avec nous là dessus tout
le monde était d'accord qu'il fallait
résister vous avez parlé de résistance
tout à l'heure à kiev ici aussi il ya un
élan de résistance mais vraiment de
manière très globale qui est très
prégnant les ukrainiens ont bien
l'intention d'en découdre quels que
soient les moyens avec ou sans arme
contre les russes autre exemple ce matin
nous avons été à l'aide à l'un des
nombreux centres de don du sang qui sont
présents dans tout le pays c'était l'un
des plus grands de dit denis pro pardon
et pour vous donner quelques chiffres
c'est environ 1000 personnes par jour
qui viennent donner leur sang qui
attendent pendant plusieurs heures pour
donner leur sang dans le froid je peux
vous dire qu'il fait très froid ici à
dnipro et ses 400 litres de sang qui
sont récoltées par jour là bas on essaye
de faire de très grandes quantités de
réserves de sang qui seront ensuite
envoyées là où ce sera nécessaire julien
vous l'avez évoqué d'un mot sur ces
volontaires est ce que vous avez dit il
sont ils sont d'une certaine manière
prêts à en découdre 6 à l'état d'esprit
des d'ukrainiens vous avez pu rencontrer
ils sont prêts à se battre c'est ça
alors oui il a beaucoup qui sont prêts à
se battre je vais vous donner quelques
exemples non loin d'ici il y avait tout
simplement
sur le trottoir sur la place publique
pour nous français c'est très étonnant
mais ici c'est dans ce contexte de
guerre effectivement ça paraît tellement
normal ça paraîtrait normal il y avait
des cocktails molotov des cocktails
molotov une avait peut-être une centaine
répartis dans des caisses que les gens
empaquetés et métiers dans les coffres
de voiture est allée ensuite
rangé ou de saison n'a patio ou ah oui
ses côtés le moteur ont été envoyés ce
qu'on sait c'est qu'ils étaient destinés
à être lancés sur les russes en tout cas
c'est ce qu'on nous a dit c'est la seule
chose qu'on a bien voulu nous dire c'est
à dire que si les russes venaient
jusqu'ici annie pro il serait accueilli
avec des cocktails molotov autre exemple
nous avons été nous avons pu aller voir
une caserne militaire qui se trouve à
quelques kilomètres de là où nous avons
rencontré des volontaires pas des
soldats des volontaires c'est-à-dire des
civils qui se sont qui ont choisi de
tout quitter pour aller d'eux mêmes
c'est à dire sans l'aval sans
l'obligation du président adamski de se
ranger aux côtés de l'armée ces
personnes-là avait d'elle-même décider
quand lorsque les rues sont attaqués
d'aller servir dans l'armée pour
combattre les russes et c'était je peux
vous dire que ça a été des moments assez
à ces déchirants parce que ces personnes
en fait son départ de famille qui ont
plusieurs enfants ils sont nous le
montrer spontanément leurs photos de
famille et nous on dit tout simplement
que la vie qu'ils avaient dans leur
jardin avec leurs petits challans
petits-enfants une vie tout à fait
normale comme vous et moi en fait et
bien pour eux c'était un chapitre qui se
refermer car un nouveau s'ouvre beaucoup
plus sombre mais en fait tout cela pour
vous dire qu'il ici il ya vraiment cet
esprit de résistance de rébellion même
si on nous dit si effectivement la
puissance militaire russe est beaucoup
plus importante que celle de l'armée
ukrainienne ils ont bien l'intention
quelles que soient les individus quel
que soit le profil quelle que soit la
méthode avec ou sans arme tout le monde
ici à l'intention de résister face aux
russes l'esprit de résistance donc de la
population ukrainienne ont leur art on
l'aura bien compris merci beaucoup
julien chez id 1 en direct donc denis
pro en ukraine pour toutes